- All right, y'all.
I save my favorite stories for the end
and this is a good one.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
All right, y'all. It seems like
everyone has a tequila brand these days.
George Clooney, Dwayne
Johnson, Nick Jonas.
But until recently,
no tequila company was
owned by a black woman.
That is until Nayana Ferguson.
The Detroit native recently
launched Anteel Tequila,
which is winning awards across the globe.
She's also a cancer survivor,
so let's get her in here.
What's up, Nayana?
(audience applauds)
- Hey, Kelly. How are you?
- I'm so good, and I love tequila,
so we could be friends.
So how did you get involved with tequila?
- So, when my husband
Don and I started dating,
he was a tequila connoisseur,
so he got me into drinking tequila.
Later down the road,
when we were both looking
for a career change,
I asked him. I said, "If
you could do anything,
what would you do?"
And he said, "Open a tequila
company. But we can't do that."
And I said, "Why not?"
So a few days later, being
the businesswoman that I am,
I found a distillery.
They sent us some samples
and we loved them.
But we wanted to do things differently.
So we created the world's only
coconut lime blanco tequila.
- Yes.
- A Reposado tequila, aged
in Tennessee whiskey barrels.
And they are both winning a lot of awards.
We have two other expressions as well.
- Oh, my gosh. That sounded amazing.
So this part is incredible to me.
You're also a pancreatic and
breast cancer survivor, right?
(audience applauds)
- Yes, I am.
- Oh my gosh.
And you're, you're healthy and
you're doing good now, right?
- Yes, I am.
I am a 16 year pancreatic cancer survivor
and a nine year breast cancer survivor.
At the time, I was a single mom,
and I knew I needed a positive mindset
to overcome those challenges.
- Yeah. I also think
that had to make you go,
"No, we can do anything we want."
Look, this is, you have to take life
and really make it happen for yourself.
I, I feel like that had
to, maybe, you said, "No."
Your husband was like,
"No, we can't do that."
And you were like, "We
could do anything we want."
I love that.
I love that it kind of
pushed you, probably.
(audience applauds)
- Yes. Beating cancer twice
really changed my perspective on life,
and I knew if I could do that,
I could overcome anything.
So when it came time to
creating Anteel Tequila,
I knew it would be difficult,
but we can do this.
- Yeah. We can do hard things.
Thank you so much, Nayana.
(audience applauds)
I cannot wait to try your tequila.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell sounds)
All right. And that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Yeah.